being here on the screen this big is  really exciting because they shot it to  be seen big no they didn't shoot it to  be seen on a phone they shot to be  seeing a huge screen with a load of  people and so when you got everybody  does it together when you cry when you  laugh everybody goes it together and I  just like kind of can't wait to get in  there and see us I'm access the best way  towards the movie and chivo the GOP  who's a complete genius a living legend  of course Alejandro is too they both  brave about what it looks like an imax  climates will be much more immersive for  much more physical and much more  emotional and intimate so it is a  spectacular performance like Oakland  people really see it in that book will  be the good one I'm afraid already  you